écrivain philosophe cinéaste romancier
un journaliste grand reporter pourrait
dire il arrive de lesbos quand gilles
arrive c'était avant le confinement
bien sûr ils viennent publier un
pamphlet qui s'appelle ce virus qui rend
fou chez grasset et sa sully bernard
henri levy bonjour bonsoir pour vous bon
jour pour nous bonjour ça se lit très
bien parce que on sent votre moteur
c'était vraiment la colère d'habitude
aux invités à qui je parle je demande la
première question à ce que comment vous
avez vécu le confinement
ben vous c'est clair vous avez pas bien
vécu ça que vous avez trouvé ça
difficile puis vous êtes en colère
expliquez nous pourquoi vous trouvez
qu'on en a trop fait je dis pas qu'on en
a trop fait jeudi que la maladie était
déjà et elle est déjà assez grave
on n'était pas obligé d'en rajouter on
n'était pas obligé de nous raconter des
conneries sur le fait que les enfants
étaient les principaux vecteurs de la
maladie
on n'était pas obligé de nous infliger à
longueur de journaux télévisés des
médecins qui se contredisaient d'un jour
à l'autre
on n'était pas obligé de le laisser nos
nos vieux lorsqu ils mourraient ce avoir
droit des enterrements de chiens on
n'était pas obligé d'avoir cette
épidémie de bêtises de gens qui nous
racontait que le confinement avaient une
grâce extraordinaire qui était de se
retrouver soi-même et que le la relation
éthique le plus fondamental c'était la
relation de soin avec soin
alors que la relation politique le plus
fondamental c'est relation de soin avec
autrui avec l'autre avec avec le frère
lointain on n'était pas obligé d'ajouter
à la maladie la connerie est la folie
il ya plusieurs choses à vous nous
raconter plusieurs choses dont une qui
est la plus douloureuse la plus grave
c'est ces gens chez vous c'est les ehpad
nous c'est les chs ldd des résidences
pour personnes âgées il ya eu des drames
il ya eu des scènes d'horreur des gens
sont morts seuls sans accompagnement
effectivement parce qu'on ne laissait
plus rentrer déjà mais est-ce qu'on
avait vraiment le choix bernard henri
lévy
est ce que parce qu'on est parti aux le
point de départ c'est que le moins de
gens meurent possible alors on s'est dit
on va tenter par toutes ces mesures là
de protéger le plus de vies possibles
c'est un objectif qui est noble nom
l'objectif est noble et c'est même la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité qu'on est l'objectif là mais
il faut être capable de compter jusqu'à
2 ou jusqu'à 3 on peut aussi mourir de
chagrin et ce qui était c'est ce qui est
arrivé à de nombreux vieux ils sont mort
de chagrin
ils sont membres de solitude on peut
aussi lorsqu'on est mort ne pas être
enterré dans un sac plastique avec des
adieux sur what's app sept en tout cas
en france et je crois que c'était le cas
aussi aux états unis et au canada
7 c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
des humains contre est comme ça les
inhumations inhumation il ya il ya eu
musset il ya homo il ya le soleil à
l'homme c'est un rite essentiel c'est un
moment fondamental dans la vie d'un
humain et de ses de sa parentèle de ses
proches
on a jeté tout ça par dessus bord on
n'était pas obligé
et puis sauver des vies oui mais compté
jusqu'à 3 ça veut dire sauver la vie de
son casse sauver la vie des villes
prospères oui de montréal de paris c'est
très bien mais ça voulait dire aussi
savoir ce que l'arrêt des économies leur
mise en coma et en carême auto-infligée
impliqué au bout de la chaîne du monde
chez des plus démunis moi je peux vous
dire que j'ai du jeu j'étais au
bangladesh juste au moment du
confinement et j'ai pu mesurer
concrètement ce que le confinement
mondiale va coûter en vies humaines mais
justement je n'ai quand vous êtes ça
parce que vous le dites beaucoup dans
votre livre il ya beaucoup de choses
tout à fait vrai mais quand vous êtes ça
vous donner de l'eau au moulin au bol
sonar eau de la planète aux gens qui
disent non il ne faut pas stopper ou à
monsieur g qu'il ne faut pas se taper
l'économie mais oui lors d'une certaine
façon
non parce que bolt sonore ou est rapide
il ya deux différences majeures
la première ceux qui se moquent
éperdument des morts alors que moi je me
je veux qu'il y en ait le moins possible
et je pense que le
l'objectif aujourd'hui d'un humaniste
c'est de sauver les vies toutes les vies
et le maximum de vies premier rang et
deuxièmement ce que disent les deux que
vous venez de citer
c'est qu'il faut se renfermer qu'il faut
ériger des frontières qu'il faut chasser
des étrangers qu'il faut [ __ ] les
mexicains dehors moi ce que je regrette
c'est au contraire cet adieu au monde
dont la crise du coc vide a aussi été
l'occasion
l'adieu au monde si vous le diront faire
ta porte et on jette la clé
moi c'est ça que je regrette hélas de ce
point de vue là pardon mais trump ou
bien et les souverainistes le français
c'est bonnet blanc blanc bonnet oui
d'ailleurs il ya un passage à la fin
vraiment très efficaces où vous dites
vous fait la nomenclature de toutes ces
crises dont on ne parle plus de gens
dont on ne parle plus parce
qu'effectivement il vous dit d'ailleurs
que l'emballement collectif aggravée par
les chaînes d'info moi j'étais 5h en
sommes tous les jours alors je peux vous
dire vous avez raison là dessus on n'a
pas beaucoup parlé d'autre chose
peut-être on aurait bien pu un peu plus
parler d'autre chose
moi j'étais pour le confinement parce
que je crois qu'il y avait pas d'autre
solution mais je pense que les
télévisions canadiennes ou françaises
pouvaient aussi en même temps qu on
confinait d'abord ne pas terroriser les
populations
on n'était pas obligé de nous terroriser
pour nous contraindre à penser que cette
maladie était grave mais surtout mais
grave d'un arrêt l'événement et bien sûr
qu'elle est grave mais naturellement
qu'elle est grave elle est gravissime
mais d'abord elle n'est pas sans
précédent
1 il ya eu on nous a dit une pandémie
sans précédent c'est pas vrai en 69 ans
58 pour ne même pas parler de la grippe
espagnole
il y a eu des pandémies et des virus
plus méchant encore que celui là un de
la mondialisation va permettre cette
fois-ci de s'en sortir plus vite que les
fois précédentes parce que production
des masques parce que production des
vaccins j'entendais avant mon passage
votre reporter ou votre commentatrice
qui me faisait un état nous la recherche
sas est à mettre au crédit d'un mondial
sur d'autres maladies graves bien sûr
que nous avons le moyen de combattre
mais troisièmement on n'était pas obligé
pendant ce temps là
de faire comme si il se passait plus
rien au yémen comme si on arrêtait
torturé en syrie comme s'il n'y avait
plus de faim de famine dans le monde
comme si poutine avait arrêté son
agression contre l'ukraine
on pouvait nom d'un chien continue que
je sais pas à consacrer les journaux
télévisés peut-être une petite partie 1
car quelques minutes
oui là dessus c'est une inflexion
intéressante enfin l'eau là où vraiment
vous marquez des points
en tout cas pour moi c'est quand vous
êtes agacé par tous ces gens qui ont dit
c'est une occasion en or c'est une
punition on allait dans le mur avec le
libéralisme la mondialisation et que le
virus nous donne l'occasion de refaire
un monde extraordinaire des licornes dit
les gens voyaient dédain se promener sur
les chances espèce de de vision un peu
utopique
vous dites c'est pas comme ça qu'on va
améliorer le monde il ya deux choses
d'abord un occasion le mot même
d'occasion est ignoble
quand il ya des morts c'est pas une
occasion un c'est pas une aucune
épidémie une tragédie
c'est pas une occasion à saisir par des
idéologues qui veulent nous fourguer
leur camelote numéro un numéro deux
derrière les gens qui s'émerveillait
d'un d'un qui traversaient les champs
elysées ou du maison gère la fenêtre du
voisin à montréal derrière ce discours
là il y avait quand même pardonnez-moi
mais y avait l'idée qu' il ya trop
d'hommes dans les villes il avait l'idée
qu'il ya quelque chose de viral dans
l'humanité et que peut-être ya le virus
mais que l'homme aussi à sa manière est
une sorte de virus non moi j'ai trouvé
ces villes vide je peux les ai trouvés
atroce une ville digne c'est une ville
morte et une ville morte
elle sent pas bon et je n'ai pas aimé le
discours de ceux qui nous ont dit je
n'ai jamais aussi bien respirer que dans
ces villes ou planer une torpeur et un
silence de miradors et de cimetières
voilà à quoi a ressemblé en tout cas
paris mais j'ai pas aimé qu'on se
réjouisse de ça en revanche je vous le
répète le confinement il fallait
évidemment passée par là mais sans la
compagne de ces espèces de réjouissance
pénitentielle sans venir nous dire qu'on
est elle enfin payer pour nos fautes et
qu'on était en train d'être châtiés par
là où nous avions voté satiété en france
du pétainisme
alors la suite vous dites d'ailleurs
vous êtes allé au camp de lesbos pour
paris match la suite comment vous voyez
la suite des choses dit le compliment
était nécessaire l'ondé confine un peu
partout vous souhaitez quoi reprendre
vos combats pour changer petit à petit
ce monde là il y en a je connais mais
mais mais moi le monde d'après j'ai pas
attendu la pandémie pour m'en soucier
moi ça fait cinquante ans que je ne
pense qu'au monde d'après c'est à dire
le monde d'aujourd'hui améliorer le
monde d'aujourd'hui réparer je pense
qu'à ça j'ai passé ma vie
donc moi j'espère que monde d'après
c'est en effet le monde d'avant en mieux
en toujours mieux tous les jours voilà
mais certainement pas considérer les
canadiens ou des français comme des rats
de laboratoire sur lesquelles on va
faire des expériences et qu'on va
transformer en est sur une seule table
rase et un agent d'une nouvelle société
sortie du cerveau fertile de quel que
soit le temps passe trop vite mais je
vais quand même entrer dans la relève et
les tempes à sauver jeu quand même
montré je vais leur montrer votre livre
après les images avaient serré la main
sur le plateau de ruquier qui a été très
gentil avec voo rire hein vous ai serré
la main pour vous c'est un acte de
résistance mais ce que ses portes le
contraire d'être responsables
actuellement que de serrer la main aux
gens écoutent et écouter d'abord serrer
la main
c'est un geste de fraternité de
solidarité c'est un geste républicain
oui deuxièmement sur le plateau de
france 2 le g les gels hydroalcooliques
sont rois avant et après le passage de
chaque invité tout est nettoyé
voilà et troisièmement sympa c'était pas
même pas un acte de résistance
je les fais par automatisme parce que
c'est vrai que pour moi elle à
l'humanité c'est pas les masques
c'est pas les gestes barrières et ça
fait cinquante ans que je me bats contre
la distanciation sociale je hais la
distanciation sociale et vous pas
aujourd'hui peut commencer à la ville ou
à la célébrer pratique oui mais la
célébrer levy et ça va être la publicité
qui va me couper je remets remonteront
le livre s'il vous plaît voilà alors le
virus qui rend fou chez grasset vraiment
j'invite les gens à le dire parce qu'il
ya matière à réflexion aussi sa dérive
des droits ce que les gens ne font pas
un échange trop facile du franc les
salles et les doigts ce qu'on n'est pas
trop docile ou responsables bref ya
matière à réflexion à des boss
intéressant c'est pour ça qu'on vous lit
merci bernard henri lévy merci à vous
merci merci merci on voit